der veranstalter hat uns jetzt
mitgeteilt es dauert noch etwas weil
corona bedingt noch nicht alle durch die
sicherheitskontrollen also den bewohner
bedingt verschärften
sicherheitskontrollen gekommen sind
einer der die sicherheitskontrollen hin
kalkar bereits erfolgreich überwunden
hat ist jetzt bei uns läuten der
parteivorsitzende die auch gestern schon
hier bei phoenix interviewt hatten das
war vor ihrer rede und die rede die sie
gestern gehalt haben gehalten haben die
zwingt uns geradezu sie noch einmal zum
interview zu bitten
am morgen sind sie mit dem gestrigen tag
auch mit der reaktion auf ihre rede
zufrieden
ja ich wusste natürlich als ich die rede
geschrieben habe dass die
widersprüchliche und konträre reaktionen
auslösen wird das preist man ein bei so
was mir erschien als notwendig und es
kam genau so wie ich es auch erwartet
hatte es gab missfallenskundgebungen es
gab aber deutlich mehr applaus
es gab am ende der rede viele die die
standen und und mehr applaudierten
es gab auch einige hielten nein karten
hoch die sich vielleicht auch getroffen
fühlten dadurch das ist so wenn man eine
rede hält wie man vielleicht als als
brandrede einstufen kann
da kann man nicht erwarten dass einem
die ganze versammlung zujubelt das war
einen ordnungsruf an die partei der mehr
notwendig erschienen also hat er wohl
auch den nerv getroffen teile der partei
auch der bundestagsfraktion sind ja von
ihnen war sie mit einer schimpfkanonade
überzogen worden um gebäude hieß es da
pubertierende schuljungen wäre das wort
corona diktatur in den mund nimmt der
verkennt dass wir keine diktatur haben
sonst gäbe es diesen parteitag gar nicht
dass hingegen alexander gauland der hier
kurz darauf im interview sagte er findet
diesen begriff völlig normal und
verfassungsgemäß haben sie das war
erreicht war was wollen sie erreichen
jetzt auch mit den erfahrungen der
letzten woche im bundestag
ich möchte dass wir unsere anliegen in
einem angemessenen ton vorbringen sehr
hart in der sache aber verbindlich im
ton und nicht überdrehen weil ich glaube
dass er mit dem überdrehen unserer
den sachschaden und das möchte ich
vermeiden ich habe übrigens jetzt nicht
irgendwelche bundestagsabgeordneter
darum prahlerei bezichtigt darin meinte
ich andere die zum beispiel vor
funkhäusern dann drohen sie würden dann
die redakteure rausholen oder sowas
ein völlig inakzeptables verhalten sowas
darf nicht sein das schadet unserem
ansehen als partei- und wenn ich da als
bundessprecher meiner partei zu
schweigen
dann glaube ich werde ich meine aufgabe
nicht gerecht deswegen muss dann wenn es
eine verbreitete disziplinlosigkeit gibt
auch in ordnungsruf mal sein
und der musste nun mal ein bisschen
kräftiger ausfallen ich habe damit
meinen frieden und halte es für richtig
so gesprochen zu haben
sie haben von inkompatibler wortwahl
gesprochen dass es begriffe da unterwegs
sind die einfach auch mit unserer
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
unvereinbar sind ist der hintergrund
auch der dass sie regelrecht
muffensausen haben von einer beobachtung
durch den verfassungsschutz weil der ist
ja droht ja sozusagen wie ein
damoklesschwert über dem haupt der afd
ich glaube der verfassungsschutz ist das
kann man gar nicht übersehen heute eine
instrumentalisierte behörde die die
feste absicht hat uns unter beobachtung
zu stellen und das völlig unbegründete
maßen
dann dürfen wir aber nicht den fehler
machen den sozusagen noch argumente frei
haus zu liefern das ist das was ich hier
was ich moniere es ist nicht ein movens
und vor dem verfassungsschutz sondern
gesagt lasst uns korrekt agieren
lasst uns in der sache hart arbeiten
aber lasst uns im ton so sein dass er
unangreifbar sind dann machen wir unsere
sache gut wäre eine beobachtung ein
kollateralschaden für die afg denn da
werden ja besonders viele
parteimitglieder der afg betroffen
beamte und offiziere die sie ja ein
überproportionaler weise auch als
mitglieder haben die ja ihn auch mit
fachlicher expertise in ihrer funktion
und partei aktivität bei stehen wäre das
ein richtiger aderlass das wäre dann ein
problem wenn die menschen
die sie ansprechen jetzt aus angst
weichen würden wenn wir sagen würden um
das ist uns unheimlich wir gehen wir
arbeiten dann natürlich dagegen
weil wir unsere mitglieder auch
informieren was heißt das eigentlich
wenn es so kommen sollte und wir werden
natürlich mit allen rechtsmitteln
dagegen vorgehen und da wir recht haben
gehen wir auch davon aus dass wir uns
sein kurzer frist durchsetzen können
nach dem rausschmiss von andreas kalbitz
hat man hörte ihr parteiinterner gegner
gesagt ich lass mir von ihm also von
leuten noch nicht die partei kaputt
machen ist da nicht irgendwann mal das
finale duell fällig der oder ich also
moment wir müssen erst mal sehen wer ist
björn hackenberg ist der thüringische
landesvorsitzende und fraktionschef im
thüringischen landtag er ist ja gar kein
bundespolitiker also solche töne habe
ich von anderen landesvorsitzenden noch
nicht vernommen
was heißt ich lasse mir von von leuten
die partei nicht kaputt machen glaubt
dass eine überhöhung seiner seiner
funktion
ich habe persönlich x-fach aufgefordert
dann kandidiere doch für den
bundesvorstand
neben bundespolitische aufgaben war es
wieder im bundesvorstand noch im
bundestag noch im konvent noch in der
bundesprogramm kommission
er engagiert sich nicht in bundes
fachausschüssen kurze ist ein reiner
landespolitiker
da sollte er vielleicht den ball dank
ein wenig flacher halten ist aber
trotzdem irgendwann mal die spaltung
unvermeidbar weil eben viele positionen
innerhalb der aktuellen fd unvereinbar
sinn da gibt es ja dort sprichwort
lieber ein ende mit schrecken als ein
schrecken ohne ende
ich sehe das ganz anders wenn ich solche
reden halte wie gestern dann denken
einige der mann will spalten die
missverstehen mich aber gründlich und
wahrscheinlich wollen sie missverstehen
ich möchte das hier in einheit eine
schlagkräftige partei sind diese eine
vitale oppositionsarbeit macht gegen die
katastrophale politik der
bundesregierung dazu brauchen wir aber
eine geschlossenheit inhaltlich und auch
im auftritt und das meine ich an
es geht also gar nicht um spaltung
sondern es geht darum die reihen zu
schließen der bundesvorstand hat gestern
vorgestern abend einen beschluss gefasst
dass die afg sich jetzt ganz besonders
an die freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung halten die die besonders in
den fokus
und ich dachte eigentlich dass das schon
immer grundlage der partei war dass es
bringt ungefähr so als würde die
römische kurie verkündet sie wolle sich
jetzt besonders streng ans zölibat
halten warum oder welchen hintergrund
hatte gerade dieser beschluss im vorfeld
des parteitags und der
auseinandersetzungen die es gerade gibt
auch um ihre personen
das ist das ist schon eine grußbotschaft
an verfassungsschutz ich sage es wieder
und wieder und wieder wir sind
rechtsstaatspartei wir stehen fest wo
der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung
da gibt es aber leute die für jeden
davon und zwar verfassungsschutz leute
die reden von einem von einem verbot der
afd
ohne jede grundlage und da tut es schon
mal klar zu machen ihr lieben leute wir
sind hier rechtsstaatspartei wir haben
die verfassungsbrüche nicht zu
verantworten die verfassungsbrüche gehen
von der regierung aus nehmen sie die dir
den bruch von artikel 16a grundgesetz im
zuge der migrationspolitik nehmen sie
die multiplen brüche der fall der der
europäischen verträge
das sind die eigentlichen vertragsbrüche
die wir haben und die haben nicht wir zu
verantworten
da müsste man hinschauen denn das ist
nicht verfassungskonform was da läuft
dann müsste man sich allerdings mit der
regierung beschäftigen und nicht mit uns
aber sie haben ja selbst gesagt dass
vieles was in der afg gerade passiert
eben auch nicht verfassungskonform nein
das habe ich nicht gesagt das würde ich
auch nicht sagen sondern ich sage wir
sollten eine wortwahl an den tag legen
die uns nicht angreifbar macht und
nehmen wir exemplarisch im begriff der
der diktatur
da meine ich ist es richtig zu sagen wir
leben nicht in einer diktatur ich habe
das auch gestern schon mehrfach gesagt
die rede von herrn bauland im parlament
an frau merkel gerichtet fand ich
ausgezeichnet das war ein kräftiger und
das war ein wohl begründeter widerspruch
ein ausgezeichneter rede
ich glaube wenn man dann den begriff der
korona diktatur benutzt dann schafft man
damit eine durch die überzeichnung die
darin liegt eine angreifbarkeit die wir
gar nicht brauchen weil wir recht haben
in der sache aber es geht nicht um
diktatur es geht um ermächtigungsgesetz
um unsägliche historische vergleiche die
eben aber auch von funktions und
mandatsträgern der afg in den letzten
tagen und wochen zum besten gegeben
worden sind machen sie sich da nicht
besonders angreifbar
ich war noch mal in dem falle der
verfassung
beobachtungen liefern sie nicht ihren
politischen gegnern die munition mit der
die dann relativ erfolgreich auf die afg
ballern können das ist das genau das was
ich gesagt habe
neben der exemplarischen begriff
ermächtigungsgesetz wenn sie sich jetzt
dass die neuerungen
infektionsschutzgesetz anschauen dann
kommt der begriff ermächtigung x-fach
vor
dann kann man daraus sagen das ist ja
immer gleich wenn man das aber tut dann
weiß jeder der diesen begriff verwendet
das ist kotiert 1933 hitlers
machtergreifung ermächtigungsgesetz 33
und dann kommt dieser schräge
zungenschlag daran dass es das problem
dass es in der tat eine ermächtigung ist
die die neuerung im
infektionsschutzgesetz bestreitet kein
mensch ich würde mit dem begriff
ermächtigungsgesetz wenn weil er eben
historisch so konnotiert ist und damit
wird ein vergleich dann schräg denn in
der tat bei allem was wir zu kritisieren
haben und ja wir haben wirklich viel zu
kritisieren die politik der regierung
ist natürlich ein vergleich mit der nazi
zeit völlig unangemessen und deswegen
sollten wir das auch nicht tun wollen
sie mit ihrem letzte frage wollen sie
mit ihrem mit ihrer strategie die afg
koalitionsfähig machen
ich möchte dass wir in unserem land eine
große politische bedeutung haben um den
verhängnisvollen kurs der regierung zu
korrigieren
ich fürchte sehr dass wir im nächsten
jahr galt schon als der opposition wir
werden absehbar der bundestagswahl 21 in
der opposition bleiben weil es überhaupt
nicht so weit ist dass man koalieren
könnte aber wenn man politik macht wenn
man politik auch gestalten das geht aus
einer regierungsfunktion natürlich
leichter die frage stellt sich nur der
zeitlich aber wir müssen nun eine
korrektur einleiten denn wir haben nicht
ewig zeit wir werden für meine begriffe
21 eine schwarz-grüne regierung bekommen
dann wird es noch schwieriger
dieses land wieder auf den vernünftigen
kurs zurückzuführen und dann müssen wir
jetzt zunächst als vitale opposition
gegen arbeiten das thema also
koalitionspartner erst dann wenn zum
beispiel für und hocke nicht mehr in der
afg sein das hat das hat damit gar
nichts zu tun
die frage stellt sich im moment auch
nicht wir werden uns nicht irgendwelchen
cdu oder spd oder grünen anbietern um
irgendwie mitregieren
können uns geht es um eine kurskorrektur
für dieses land werden wir partner
finden mit denen wir das machen können
und auch die stärke dafür haben das tun
zu können
dann wird sich die frage irgendwann
stellen das wird aber nicht jetzt seien
sogar direkten parteivorsitzender im
phoenix interview
danke dass sie da waren